I'm gonna end it if it doesn't end
well the end is here at least for Kevin
Costner and John Dutton sources close to
Yellowstone's production telling E.T
he's not returning after season five you
should think twice I've found plenty
about it now the season hasn't finished
shooting reportedly due to Onset drama
Kevin allegedly feuding with the show's
co-creator Taylor Sheridan over his
filming commitments
he will use everything that he knows to
destroy you
he has made it clear
yes I believe he has my guess is that
the version of Yellowstone that we know
is probably going to end with this
season I think the negativity right now
has gotten to a point where it's going
to be very difficult for him to come
back to the show as far as where the
other cast and crew stand additional
sources say there's still no update on
when they're going to finish shooting in
Montana where the series is filmed as a
result there's been a lot of confusion
and frustration I mean
drama with Yellowstone Rumblings of
Kevin wanting out of the show ramped up
earlier this year but there's been also
disbelief amongst the cast that he would
ever exit the hit series don't believe
everything you hear unless it comes from
Beth okay do you feel that there's a lot
more story to tell left on Yellowstone
always
he's such a movie star and it's just
like really inspiring to be around an
actor like that he couldn't go nowhere
is Kevin Costner come on now he's the
best no he's he's awesome like this is a
cowboy world right where it's about it's
kind of about being in the moment of
Taylor's Vision right so I think so much
of it has to do with when Taylor says
these are the scripts they're ready I
think that's really where we're all kind
of at that point of waiting Kevin
probably is too and so he also is
directing a movie right now so there's
you know life right life is a big
complicated journey and we're trying to
tell a big complicated story and we've
got a lot of very interesting people who
are all trying to do it together there's
a lot that I still need to learn I mean
um
you know what will I regret when I do
believe you know shuffle off you know
it's probably the books shall never have
read and the songs I'll Never Have Heard
the stories you know there's stuff left
ET has reached out to Kevin's rep and
the show's rep for comment
[Music]